[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم المجتمع الدولي يقدم رجلا ويؤخر
اخرى الخلافات الدائمه بين اعضائه
الدائمين تقف مره اخرى في وجه محاوله
لحمايه اهالي حلب والتخفيف من معاناتهم
فقد اعترضت روسيا من جديد على مشروع قرار
فرنسي بهذا الشان واتجه المجلس الى مناقشه
مشروع بديل يوم غد الاثنين اما في حلب
وضواحيها فيستمر الترقب لساعه الخلاص لكن
منطق المساومات والمقاضاة
مع محمد
ابراهيم ابو يعلو صوت اصحاب الرايات
المواليه لايران ومتطرفين اخرين في اتفاق
تهجير حلب ويخف صوت الضحايا والمنكوبين
فلا يكاد يبدا تنفيذ الاتفاق الذي اريد
منه اتمام اخراج جميع السكان حتى يتوقف
سريعا خلال ايام اعترضت ميليشيا حزب الله
اللبناني والنجباء العراقيه القافلات
المغادره وقتلت مدنيين ونكلت باخرين في
مسعا لفرض شروط جديده اقحمت على الاتفاق
وكان لها ذلك بضم بلدتي كفريه
والفوعة الزيت على النار وفي مصلحه
المفاوض الايراني بالدرجه الاولى عرقله
سير الاتفاق بعد نسخته الثالثه المعدله
اعادت المشهد من جديد الى ما يعانيه
المدنيون في حلب والى الشروط القاسيه التي
تفرض عليهم للتهجير من قبل مختلف الاطراف
فيما تبقى من هذا المشفى الميداني يلح
عشرات الجرحى في المناش بانقاذ الحالات
الحرجه منهم وفي طرقات يحيطها الدمار من
كل صوب وتشهد على ما حل بالشهباء من مصاب
يتجمع الالاف من اهلها في انتظار مسير
قوافلهم وسط ظروف انسانيه ماساويه وخشيه
تعرضهم لانتهاكات المتربصين بهم ازاء
المشهد الحلبي المروع ما تزال الامم
المتحده الغائبه الاكبر في مجلس الامن
مشروع قرار فرنسي يؤكد على ان تكون عمليات
اجلاء المدنيين طوعا والى الوجهه التي
يختارونها المشروع يقترح نشر مراقبين
لضمان المرور الامن لكنه وئد من قبل موسكو
قبل قل ان يولد ووضعت امامه مشروعا مضادا
يوافق طروحاتها ليبقى السجال سيد الموقف
في اهم محفل دولي فروسيا هي راعيه الاتفاق
الكبير في حلب ومن ترى بان يدها هي العليا
في ظل غياب اي دور اوروبي وامريكي او حتى
عربي فيما ظهرت ايران لاعبا رئيسا اخر على
الارض ودخلت على خط التفاوض والقرار بشان
حلب ولم يتردد جنرال الموضوع على قوائم
الارهاب الدوليه قاسم سليماني في توثيق
حضوره على اشلاء حلب وانزوى بشار الاسد
امام كاميرا هاتف في دمشق يستعرض
نصره ما رح تن من الغوط ما رح نطلع
بانتظار توافق الدول على باقي مرحله تهجير
اهالي حلب يعيش اخرون في دوما ومناطق اخرى
هاجس ان ياتي الدور عليهم في قراءه واضحه
لتوجهات القوى العظمى لا تتدخل من اجل
انصاف المدنيين وحمايتهم من بطش النظام
فترى في التهجير الحل
الاسهل لمناقشه هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا من
عمان شارمين محمد المستشاره في الشان
السوري والمجلس النرويجي للاجئين ومن
باريس الدكتور جورج صبره عضو الهيئه
العليا للمفاوضات في المعارضه السوريا
ورئيس المجلس الوطني السابق اهلا بكما
وابدا معك دكتور جورج صبرا في باريس مره
اخرى دكتور يفشل مجلس الامن في التوصل
لاتفاق يخفف من معاناه
المدنيين في حلب يعني لما تعزون هذا
التعثر او استمرار بالاحرى هذا التعثر
وهذا الفشل في مجلس
الامن يعني هذا نهج
روسي ظهر امام الجميع منذ زمن بتعطيل مجلس
الامن ومنعه من اتخاذ القرارات المناسبه
بالشان السوري بدا ذلك منذ وقت مبكر منذ
عام
2012 ويستمر حتى اليوم وبدا ببدعه جديده
منذ فتره وهي ان يواجه مشاريع القرارات
التي تقدمها هذهه الدوله او تلك هذه
المجموعه او تلك بمشاريع قرارات مناوئه
يعرف ان لا حظ لها من الاستمرار للاسف
ينكشف الان امام العالم ان الايراني
وميليشياته الطائفيه يعيقون اخلاء الجرحى
والمدنيين من حلب ويقوم الروسي بالحلول
دون ان تتم هذه العمليه تحت اشراف الامم
المتحده وتحت انظار المراقبين الدوليين
خاصه بعد مجريات اليومين الماضيين على ارض
الواقع عندما تعرضت
قوافل المدنيين السوريين الذين يغادرون
واجبروا على مغادره حلب قسم منهم تعرض
للقتل قسم تعرض لاطلاق النار واصابات
الجرحى قسم تعرض للنهب والسلب لاموال ه
ومقتنياته ثم اعيد وبهذه الظروف الصعبه
ينام عشرات الالاف من النساء
والاطفال والشيوخ المدنيين في الاقبيه
والشوارع ينتظرون فرصه الخروج من حلب تلك
العمليه التي بدات ولكن للاسف يقوم
الايراني على الارض ويقوم الروسي في مجلس
الامن في منع هذه العمليه وايقافها وامع
التنكيل
بالمدنيين السوريين ا طيب يعني بالاضافه
الىى ما ذكرت دكتور يعني بالفعل مجلس
الامن كما تقول بدا منذ مده طويله منذ ست
سنوات لم يتخذ قرارا مهما بشان سوريا كان
يصطدم دائما كما تقول بالفيتو الروسي الان
حتى الاعاقه الايرانيه والروسيه الان بدت
واضحه حتى على الارض هل تراهنون انتم على
تصويت الغد ربما في ان يحدث فرقا في ماساه
حلب
يعني دائما نحن نعتقد في عمليه انسانيه
مثل هذه العمليه استجلبت الاهتمام الدولي
ان يكون لمجلس الامن دور فيها فاذا كان
مجلس الامن هذه الجهه التي انيط بها الحفظ
على الامن والاستقرار في العالم التي انيط
بها تنفيذ القانون الدولي والقانون الدولي
الانساني لا تستطيع ان تقوم بدورها في مثل
هذه الحاله فهناك سؤال ما هي هذه الامم
المتحده لذلك نحن نرى ان الاجراء الروسي
ليس فقط ينكل بالسوريين لكن هل مازال ت
ظ دكتور صبرا يعني هل ما زال التعويل على
مجلس الامن في ان يقوم بشيء بعد هذا
الغياب يعني مجلس الامن كما تقول كان
الغائب الحاضر منذ مده طويله هل هل مازال
لديكم الامال هل تعودون الامال على جلسه
الغد على سبيل
المثال حقيقه لم يعد للسوريين اي امل في
ذلك بعد هذا الفشل المتكرر وال والانكى من
ذلك يتم ذلك بالتوازي ذراع على الارض تقوم
بالقتل والتشريد و
واستباحه حقوق الناس ويد اخرى في الفضاء
السياسي الدولي في الامم المتحده تمنع
انصاف هؤلاء الضحايا واخراجهم وفق القانون
الدولي الانساني بكرامه فعلا ووفق ما
تقتضيه الاعراف الدوليه حقيقه نحن لم نعد
نرى اي ظل للامم المتحده ولا لمجلس الامن
الدولي ا سيده شرمين محمد في عمان يعني
عشرات الالاف معهم الاطفال الان في العراء
يفترشون الارض في درجات حراره تحت حت
الصفر انتم كمنظمات دوليه اي دور لكم في
التخفيف من هذه
المعاناه حقيقه لنا وضعان هنا هنا
المدنيون الذين مازون
محجوزين سواء ولا وصول لمساعده الانسانيه
ومدنيون تمكنوا من الخروج من ويحصلون على
بعض المساعده ولكن في الحدود هناك عوائق
كثيره لوصول المساعدات الى الناس في الوقت
الحاضر مجلس اللاجئين النرويجي يساعد
الخارجين ونستجيب بالمو والغذاء ولكن
الناس في
وضع ماساوي حقا
يصلون ليس لهم لا ملابس ويشع يون بالبرد
الشديد
ويجدون المساعدات من كل من لديهم
الامكانيه المساعده تتحدثين عن عوائق على
الحدود يعني ما طبيعه هذه العوائق وهل
تسمح لكم السلطات الروسيه في ايصال بعض
هذه المساعدات
لهؤلاء ان كانوا ما زالوا محاصرين في
الداخل او النازحين او الخارجين من هذه
المناطق
المحاصره
هناك مدنيون لا يمكنهم الوصول الى
المساعدات الانسانيه في اي مكان جميع
الاطراف تمنع المنظمات الانسانيه من
الوصول اليهم في
داخل شرق حلب هناك عوائق وعقبات
كثيره وايضا في الريف الذين وصلوا الى
الريف يحصلون على بعض المساعدات ولكن ما
يزال هناك حاجه الى القيام بالمزيد في
ظروف الشتاء
القارس وقبل ان ربما يتعرض الكثيرون للقتل
او للموت اعود لك دكتور جورج صبره يعني
مشروع فرنسي
رفضته روسيا لوحت بالفيتو الروسي اليوم
وهناك مشروع معدل روسي مطروح الان اولا هل
اطلعتم عليه انتم في المعارضه السوريه هل
هو مرض
لكم حقيقه جرى اضطلاع عن طريق الصحافه
التي نشرت بعض التفاصيل عن المشروع
الفرنسي وهو مشروع منسجم مع القانون
الانساني الدولي ومنسجم مع مهام الامم
المتحده بالذات لا انا اتحدث عن المشروع
الروسي المعدل دكتور دكتور صبره يعني
المشروع الفرنسي نحن
نعلم ما ماهيته لكن المشروع المعدل الروسي
الذي تحدث عنه مندوب روسيا اليوم في الامم
المتحده فيتالي
توركن حقيقه لم يصل الينا التفاصيل ذات
قيمه عن هذا المشروع الروسي لكن ببساطه
نحن نقارن بما حدث خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين عندما قامت ايضا روسيا
ب مناقضه المشروع الفرنسي وتقديم مشروع
بديل لا يمكن القبول فيه ا
هذه عمليه جديده اهتدى اليها الروس في ان
يواجهوا القرارات التي يمكن فعلا ان تحل
القضايا وتساعد على فتح افق جديد في
الازمه السوريه بقرارات لا يمكن الموافقه
عليها فقط لاضاعه الوقت هذا هو ديدن الروس
خلال هذه الفتره شكرا لك اذا دكتور جورج
صبره عضو الهيئه العليا للمفاوضات في
المعارضه السوريه ورئيس المجلس الوطني
السابق كنت معنا من باريس ونشكر من عمان
شارمين محمد
مستشاره الشان السوري بالمجلس النرويجي
للاجئين في الملف الثاني حسن جمول وهجمات
على قوى الامن العام في مدينه الكرك جنوبي
الاردن